Right,
there is already a lot of collaboration
going on between a European countries
and China and,
uh,
between us and China,
and this is necessary from so many
different perspectives.
Um,
China is part of the WTO.
It is the major,
you know,
economy gradually will be,
and it's a sustainable development and
climate area.
It is essential for the global future.
So no doubt there has to be
collaboration and China is going to
develop.
They are,
they have ambitions and uh,
we have to realize that those ambitions
are not different from the ambitions
that,
uh,
the dominated in our own countries when
our countries were being developed,
uh,
and new technologies were being put into
a function.
Uh,
so the best thing we can do is to be
collaborative and a secret that the
patterns that are used are inspired by
future technologies.
And it will benefit all of us.
I,
you know,
this,
uh,
being so afraid about competitiveness,
I have never understood,
even as a prime minister.
I mean,
unless you have products or services to
sell to others outside your own country,
then you better look for,
uh,
other things that you can do better.
We live in a,
in a world where we all benefit from
doing what we are best at doing and,
and use our minds and our efforts to
promote a development pattern that
benefits all of us.
So this year,
this drama about being so scared about
everybody else,
I have never really taken onboard.